camilo buenas noches cuál es su balance
de la implementación luego de cinco años
del acuerdo de paz
bueno el balance es muy precario
a esa altura de tener más del cuarenta
ciento pero cursos implementados
pero las cifras no pasan de por ciento
ya ese ritmo algunos temas podemos
gastar los 30 años más un tema de
tierras incluso puedes hacer hasta 80
años porque deseado trabajado
parcialmente a puertas gotas y el
gobierno que busca representar el gol en
un referendo que esto esté superado por
eso de la república
considerase legítimos la puerta entonces
tenemos una situación crítica para la
implementación
y usted no se está hablando de unos años
que superan por mucho las estimaciones
de cuánto se iba a demorar la
implementación y en ese sentido la
promesa era precisamente una paz estable
y duradera en colombia que tanto ha
contribuido realmente el acuerdo de la
habana a esto
por la verdad que hay un fenómeno social
es que colombia amplio cuerpo de paz
representa una revolución de ciencia de
la inmensa mayoría al 80 por ciento de
los colombianos se manifiestan pues
también las calles a aborden el acuerdo
en contra de la guerra
eso es una transformación
fabulosa pero por supuesto contrasta con
la persistencia de dinámica de guerra
discurso del odio
desconocimiento de la ley a los acuerdos
desde el propio gobierno y el partido
del gobierno y todo ese conjunto
facilitan la reproducción de violencias
ha ido más rápido en la red de
violencias mafiosas que la presencia del
estado de los ritos colombianos y pienso
se ha reflejado en el asesinato del
líder en masacres en una ética de
violencias distintas del pasado no tan
intensas o antes del acuerdo pero todas
maneras tremendamente nocivas trans
social colonial
usted nos está hablando de la
implicación de las bandas mafiosas en la
violencia en colombia puede profundizar
nos por favor un poco más en este
sentido cuáles son esos grupos y cuál es
la situación de seguridad en colombia
después del acuerdo
disminuyeron casi todas las violaciones
el próximo aniversario los grandes
equipos contra la corrupción pero
posteriormente a la lentitud de
different acción más desarrollados y
pasiones a presupuestos grupos
incidentes estos fueron de acuerdo con
la pipa o que se abrieron el proceso y
se ha reorganizado en las mafias
herederas del espacio arismo tenemos
cerca de 3.500 hombres en armas en estos
grupos neoparamilitares y alrededor de
3000 en lo que fue la recomposición de
disidentes o residuos de los que fueron
las farc son grupos distintos no tienen
estrategia de poder ni estrategia
políticas la mayoría están en redes por
rentas por servicios de ese cambias pero
perturban la situación facilitan la
militarización y dificultan la
transición al conflicto
camilo muchas gracias por su análisis y
por toda la información